جلسه مسائله هناك الثالثه في البرلمان قد
تكون الاصعب بعد اضطرار الوزيري جبن وليم
سنت المعين في الحكومه من دون حقيبه الى
ترك منصبه بسبب اتهامات بالتنمر وارسال
رسائل غير مقبوله لاحد اعضاء حزبه زعيم
المعارضه العماليه وجه ثلاثه اسئله محرجه
لسناك انتقد فيها تعامله مع قضيه وليامسن
وخشيته من مواجهه الناس في انتخابات عامه
[موسيقى]
نادم على اعادته الى مجلس الوزراء
اوبليسليف من الواضح انني اسف لتعيين شخص
اضطر الى الاستقاله في هذه الظروف لكني
اعتقد ان ما يود الشعب البريطاني ان يعرفه
هو انه عندما تظهر مثل هذه المواقف سيتم
التعامل معها بشكل صحيح وهذا هو السبب
استقالته واتمام اجراء تحقيق للنظر في هذه
الامور بشكل صحيح وكما قلت ان حكومه ستتسم
بالنزاهه والاحترافيه والمسؤوليه
[تصفيق]
كانت واضحه من النواب المعارضين لاعتبارهم
ان الحكومه لم تلتزم بمعيار النزاهه
والمسئوليه في قضيه وليامسن وهم يطالبون
بتقديم تقرير كامل عن سبب اعاده تعيينه
وزيرا هذا في وقتناك المزيد من الضغوط على
خلفيه تعيين ولا برافا من وزيره الداخليه
بعد ايام من اقالتها لانتها قواعد وزاريه
الهجوم على سوناك لم يقتصر على تعييناته
بل شمله ايضا عندما فرض ضرائب اضافيه على
ارباح شركات الطاقه غير المتوقعه الى جانب
عدم الغاء ميزه الضريبي على الدخل الاجنبي
رئيس الحكومه رئيس السوناك يحاول ان تلحق
استقالته باضرار اعمقه حكومته لكن
المعارضه التي تضع كل قراراته تحت مجهارها
لن تتوانى عن ملاحقه كل صغيره وكبيره على
صله بحكمته من اعاده تعيينه وزيره
الداخليه بره من وصولا الى قراراته بشان
المساعدات والضرائب مصطفى زارو العربيه
لندن